uh thank you very much Julia and Luka
for inviting me and giving me this great
spot in the schedule so I'm going to use
it as kind of a commercial break to
advertise some uh problems which I think
are really important and uh so the main
I mean the result is something from a
few years ago which we proved with
Sergey norin it's about it's a very
general result but uh in extremal comics
and there are some very general and I
think very important open problems there
which I'm going talk about later in the
talk um so let me start uh by being a
bit vague and just talk about what is
the general approach here general area
that we study so extremal graph Theory
we know it's a very old area it dates uh
dates to some uh over for more than a
century ago result a mantle about
densities of
triangles uh density of a graph to
be
uh uh The Edge dens it required to see a
triangle in a graph and there are many
results since then and many different
proofs and ideas but we see some
techniques are very common in this area
like koshar as we have already seen in
some of the previous stocks and say
other things like induction and uh there
are new results or new way of looking at
this whole area from a very general
perspective and the works of fredman
loas dver then subsequent works by SE R
Bor and other people which kind of
explain why we see for example why K
Schwarz is such a powerful tool in this
area and uh turns out there is some rich
algebraic structure between this uh uh
underlying many of these techniques and
that's kind of explains these things and
as a consequence uh we find neater proof
like soft more soft proofs as uh for
example what Terry was saying talking in
the previous talk we can get rid of
epsilons and low order terms and proof
look neater and the actually more
amazing thing is that uh we find some
powerful techniques which kind of were
overlooked previously to prove things in
a semi-automatic way and these were very
successful in the past three or four
years so I'm going to mention a few uh
amazing consequences of this so uh in
extral graph Theory or extral graph
theory of dense graphs basically we are
interested in the following quantity so
we count the number of copies of a graph
H and G in a think of G as a huge graph
and H as a small graph and normalize it
properly uh we can think of these as
moments of the graph G so as in
statistics when you have a distribution
You' look at the moments uh or a random
variable look at the moments here we
kind of think of these as uh kind of a
statistics statistics of the graph G so
we can look at these and try to
understand Global things about the graph
G so natil lineal gave a talk about
these things and advertised them in the
uh beginning of this uh semester here in
Simons and he was saying that this kind
of can be thought of as some new branch
of Statistics where we have these huge
graphs say coming from biology or from
social networks and we can we want to
treat them as distributions or something
like that look at these samples we can
take samples and uh kind of estimate
these densities and by looking at them
say something about like make a guess
for the big graph as you do in
statistics saying that this looks like a
normal distribution or posum
distribution things like that so it's
very important to understand the
relations between these
things and if you look at the literature
of extreme graph Theory you see that
many of the many of the results in this
area can be interpreted or Rewritten as
basically inequalities between these
subgraph densities for small gaps such
as mantal theum I'm going to mention
later and there is a kind of a important
theorem which is one of the first
theorems which initiated this way of
looking at the area is that says that
every such inequality follows from the
fact that some infinite uh infinite
Matrix which I'm going to formally
Define later is positive semi-definite
so just POS this positive semi-definite
fact implies all these
inequalities uh and you can interpret
this as saying that all these
inequalities follow
from possibly infinitely many
applications of kosart so you apply all
these Kos schares you add them up and
you get the inequality so every
inequality can be proved in this
way and uh rasor of continuing this work
uh defined actually a formal calculus
which included these koses and also some
other things like induction and kind of
defined a more formal calculus calculus
for proving these
inequalities um
okay so uh I'll mention before going to
before giving you the formal definitions
I'll mention some of the incredible
applications uh of this thing so one is
that now we have basically an automatic
way of proving things which was very
successful so it's basically you write
your inequality as uh you feed it to an
semi-definite program solver and in many
cases it just gives you immediately aove
basically without without even trying
anything so for example rasboro uh this
is one of the first applications he just
uh he found significant improvements
over the best known bounds for Tan hyper
graph problem which some people consider
one of the most important problems in
extremal graph Theory and two of the
other applications that just I was
involved was the conjecture of saranu
and in independently by Jager stoich and
Thomason and again it's we didn't do
really any uh uh like any thinking here
just we plug the problem to the program
and spit out to proof for us and another
thing was even a conjecture of aish
about density of five Cycles again
really no mathematical struggling it's
just a computer and but you can also
involve them as uh with you uh add this
extra power to your usual thinking power
so you can um this is a powerful
Machinery which can assist us and
another I mean a very important example
is rasboro proof that uh found the exact
relation between minimal density of
triangles given a exact formula for
minimal density of triangles knowing the
edge density of a graph and uh he prove
tun's hypergraph problem again under
extra M conditions and these are from
the beginning of this uh from few years
ago and recently it's just there's so
many applications now that I can't
really list all of them but just I mean
very recently I saw a paper again
another conjecture where they Sol with
this I mean with very little effort most
of the work was done again by computer
even you can sometimes apply them to
unexpected problems really they don't
they're not even about Edge density of
graphs for example Crossing number of
complete bipartite graphs Serge noran
and uh Yori which they improve the bond
significantly for this using this SCP
Machinery so when you look at these
applications the first question you ask
is that well how far can you go maybe
you can just prove everything using uh
this Machinery like maybe there's an
algorithm which can prove everything
maybe the only trouble is that computers
are not powerful enough that's why we
can't prove some conjectures of air
desure things like that and so Ras borov
actually writes this this is a direct
quote from uh his paper on flag algebra
and he said stated this as saying that
he thinks this is the most important
problem in extral com rhetorics that is
it true that every true algebraic
inequality between subgraph densities
can be proved using a finite amount of
manipulations with sub subgraph denses
of finitely many
graphs and then he actually re uh like
States some formalized some uh precise
conjectures uh and uh what we did is we
prove undecidability result basically
gives a very negative answer to these
questions all these questions right that
no this like lack of computer
computational power is not the obstacle
actually these problems are inherently
difficult so now uh I'll try to be more
precise give you the formal definitions
so U external graph Theory as I
mentioned earlier in the talk it's
about understanding the relation between
densities of graphs instead of densities
I'm going to work with something similar
called homomorphism densities and these
two are equivalent in some sense U up to
just some little o error and some just
normalizing factor depense and let me
Define it uh theomorphism density of a
graph H in a big graph G is the
probability that a random map is Edge
preserving so I'm going to map vertices
of this small graph H uniformly and
independently at random ver of G and I'm
interested in the probability that all
the edges were mapped to edges so this
red arrows here correspond to a valid
homomorphism all the edges are mapped to
edges there right I'm going to denote
this by T subh of G and uh another way
so these maps are called homomorphisms
and this basically is the probability
that a random map is a
homomorphism and asymptotically as I
mentioned earlier these two are
equivalent so we can just pick whatever
whichever we want and work with that and
this T like homomorphism density is a
bit more convenient because we don't
require the map to be for example
injective and the automorphisms of the
graph are irrelevant um and so we get
nice identities so for example the
following which I'm going to use later
is that if you have two graphs H1 and H2
and if you look at their disjoint Union
I'm going to have the following identity
that the probability that a random map
from the disjoint Union is a homor phys
is just a product of the uh probability
that the first map mapping this part
gives you a homomorphism times
the probability that mapping this other
graph gives you a homomorphism right
everything is independent so I want all
these edges to be mapped to edges and
all these edges here mapped to edges so
I can just multiply that so I get this
nice
identity uh okay so uh we can State many
classical results in this language for
example good man's bound says that the
density of triangles is lower bounded by
the following twice the density of edges
squared minus the edge density I'm going
to use this result actually later uh so
it's a neat inequality between these
densities another thing is that now any
such algebraic inequality I can actually
convert it to a linear inequality using
what I had in the previous slide so here
the problem is that I have a quadratic
inequality this is squared but uh I know
how to uh
turn that into just the power one I can
write this as just T of K2 disjoint
Union K2 right two disjoint Union of
edges so by what I had in the previous
slide these two are equal so I get a
linear inequality like that so I can
State Goodman's well in the following
way um okay so more notation um so in
I'm going to work with something more
General than graphs and those are called
partially labeled graphs so what is a
partial label graph is just a graph
where some of the vertices are labeled
with say natural numbers so for example
this graph from four Vertes is a partial
label graph this this one is labeled
with two this one is labeled with three
and these two ones are not
labeled okay and now I want to
generalize this homeomorphism density to
partially labeled graphs uh so recall
that this was the probability that a
random map is a
homomorphism uh now
so when I have a partially labeled graph
I also will require to a to have a map
from the set of labels to G which will
tell me where do labeled gra labeled
vertices will go so uh F tells me where
each label should be mapped and then
I'll Define this probability given five
to be the probability that I'm going to
get a homeomorphism if I respect five so
if if my map is an extension of five F
restricted to L is five so think of
these labeled vertices as you pin them
on the graph and then you map everything
else randomly and you want to get a
homeor attach to specific or yes so some
nodes are labeled uh in the graph Edge
and this map five tells you where those
should go and then after that you do the
problemistic step so here I have this uh
one labeled graph F tells me that this
vertex should go here and now the t is
defined as will be 3 over 4 so the only
way to get a homeomorphism is to map
this other unlabeled vertic to one of
these three vertices so three over out
of the six choices I have so I get half
kind of is gives me normalized degree of
this vertex for
example um so another notation is this
bracket operator will just erase the
label so if I have a labeled graph I can
if I write it in this uh bracket it
means that I'm erasing the lab label so
it will convert this labeled vertex to
an unlabeled vertex here and uh it has a
meaning analytic meaning I can think of
this as taking a random file right so if
I average all these maps all these
densities with fixed FES over a choice
of random F I'm going to get just the
probability that a random map is a
homomorphism so uh I'll get this
identity just erasing means erasing
labels means averaging over random FES
okay
uh so recall that I had this identity
here and motivated by this identity I
can Define the product of
two graphs to be just a d joint Union so
I just basically convert this to an a
definition I'm defining the product of
two graphs to be their disjoint
union now I want to Define similarly the
products of partial labeled
graphs uh let me give you first the
definition and then say what what
identity it corresponds to so what I'll
do is I'll take their disjoint Union as
I do for unlabeled graphs but then I'll
identify vertices with the same
labels okay and then but this might lead
to multiple edges and in that case I'll
just keep one of them so for example
take these two partial label graphs I
want to multiply them I'm identifying uh
one with one two with two three with
three and um because of that I'm going
to see for example a multiple Edge
between one and two it exists in both
but I'm going to just keep one of them
one is adjacent to three here I'll have
that edge three is adjacent to two I'll
have that edge so on so I'll keep all
the edges between labeled graphs in both
graphs and then the unlabeled vertices
will be just remain D joyed so this part
will remain here as kind of a tangle
part and this other one here right so
it's just a just gluing the two graphs
over the labeled vertic is according to
the
labels now why is this a good
definition uh suppose I have two graphs
with labels L1 and L2 and I have a map
which tells me where do labels should go
so five maps all the labels in L1 Union
L2 to
G um now I claim that I have the
following
identity if I uh multiply these two
things for morphism density of H1 and H2
then I'll get theomorphism density of H1
* H2 so let's see why that's true so I
have these two labeled graphs F tells me
where do labeled vertices should go so
uh note that in both sides to get a
homomorphism I need to map all the edges
between red vertices correctly right to
edges otherwise I'm going to get zero in
both sides so if five Maps any edge here
say three to Edge between three to three
and two to a non-edge I'm going to get
zero here and I'm going to get zero here
because both of them are mapping these
label vertices the same way and then I'm
keeping all the adenes between red
vertices and the other thing now once
you condition on that these two events
become independent the other vertices
are being mapped independently right
so take uh and so condition on these
green arrows then take any map that Maps
this part randomly and this part
randomly I can just combine those two
maps and get a map which maps all these
two vertices randomly and again it's
just in both sides I'm just looking at
the probability that all these
adjacencies between uh red vert between
blue vertices and also between blue and
red vertices are mapped correctly it's a
very simple uh observation but uh so it
says kind of shows that this definition
that we had is a good definition for PR
prod so as I said uh well the whole
thing we looking at is are these linear
inequalities between homeomorphism
densities and we want to see when do
when are they valid for all graphs G for
example Goodman's bound we saw before
that's something which is valid for all
graphs okay so let's see how we can
prove such an inequality I'm going to
give you a way of proving those consider
a set of uh partially labeled graphs
with labels coming from a set
L and pick some coefficients so these
are just real numbers that can be
negative positive and the map five which
tells me where labels go to this graph G
now let's do the following let's look at
this sum sum of b t h 5 of
G um so this can be a negative number
positive number I'm going to square it
to make sure that it's a positive number
so this is at least zero now we can
expand this so what will be the
expansion
I'll get this double sum b i BJ t h I5
tji but now I know what this is by my
definition right so this is nothing but
uh T of hi I * 5 uh HJ the way I Define
before this gluing operator and five of
G so I know that any this inequality
holds right so for any graph G and any
given fi this is always positive with
this partial label graph so this is not
exactly what we wanted excuse
me uh the reason is I have this F but
how do I get rid of five I've already
mentioned this before right so you can
just average now over all random FES uh
so this is what we proved in the
previous step and now if I average over
five take the expected value over five
uh well it's still going to be positive
because this is positive for all five so
this will just means that removing the
labels so this is a way of proving such
inequalities any BJ any set of partial
labeled graphs I have this identity this
is always positive do you aaging overall
five fixed number of labels uh or does
it matter uh yeah I mean labels are
coming from the set l i mean I have a
finite set of finite
graphs uh okay
okay so I know that I can prove such
inequalities so these are always
positive uh so uh okay so let me
say uh so suppose I have these partial
labeled graphs now I know the following
facts so for every graph G first of all
tk1 of G is always one right that's
always the case uh another trivial
identity is that that if I take the
union of H and K1 D joint Union this is
going to be just T of G * tk1 of G which
is the same as TK of because of the
first condition and the third condition
is that uh this infinite Matrix whose i
j entry is this is positive
semi-definite this is the definition of
positive semidefinite for this Matrix
right whose entries are these so for
every graph G I have this positive
semidefinite Matrix um and it turns out
this result of fredman L and Sh that I
mentioned earlier is that these three
conditions suffice to characterize the
relation between all these subgraph
densities so if I have a map T which
satisfies these three conditions it
means that it's a density of these
graphs in some graph G right so given
such a map I can construct a g uh in the
limit actually it's not exactly G but
it's a limit of this like a graph on
what Terry T T
before uh but uh in other words if we
could optimize over this semi-definite
positive semide definit of this infinite
Matrix we could solve all those linear
inquality um okay uh so next notation
I'm going to Define is just going to
it's a very abstract thing and it just
simplifies writing thing so it's not I
mean it's basically an abstract abstract
nonsense
in um so a Quantum graph is a just a
formal linear combination of graphs so
given any set of graphs H1 to HK and
some numbers I'll Define this formal
linear combination as uh call it quantum
graph there's no semantic C it's just a
definition now uh we call it positive if
for every graph G the following identity
holds so our goal is to understand what
is the set of positive Quantum
graphs for example good bounds
corresponds to the fact that this
Quantum graph is
positive
um okay um we can do the same thing with
partially labeled Quantum graphs I can
look at their formal linear
combinations
um and call them Quantum partially
labeled Quantum graphs now I know how to
multiply two partially labeled Quantum
graphs I can extend it to this Quantum
uh partial label Quantum graphs uh to
turn it into an algebra so given these
two linear combinations formal linear
combinations the product is defined the
following way so you just expand it and
then take payo products which is we know
how to do it just glue them over the
labels right so this turns this whole
partial label Quantum graphs into an
algebra and I have this linear operator
which was erasing the uh labels a linear
operator from this algebra to this other
algebra and for example what uh we did
in a few slides ago squaring and then
unlabeling corresponds to this identity
here so you can square it expand it you
get this and then this is a linear
operator so you can just take it in get
this
identities um so what this said before
uh what this says is that given any
labeled Quantum graph the following is
positive we saw that
before now uh this was one way of
constructing positive Quantum graphs I
can also add them up if I have a bunch
of quantum graphs I can just add them
and get another positive Quantum graph
so
uh
given partially labeled Quantum graph G1
to GK if I Square them and add them up
and then unlabeled I'm going to get an
another valid inequality and this
question uh due to low SE and in a
slightly different form to as Bor of uh
as whether is it true that
any valid inequalities or in other words
any positive Quantum graph can be
expressed as the sum of finite number of
squares sums of squares of this finite
number of quantum graphs and uh it was
quite a coincidence apparently this is
listed in lass's list of open problems
problem 17 it's really related to
Hilbert 17th problem and according to
let's see this was a coincidence so it
wasn't
intentional
uh okay
so no unfortunately not but what we
solve is kind of a 10 problem in the end
yeah I don't know if it can be changed
ask him
to so uh loas SED and independent Ras
borov observed that the following is
true if we if we only interested in
approximation we can do this if f is
positive then we can approximate it with
the sums of a square for any Epsilon you
find a k and this nice expression that
the difference is so this basically says
if you're caring about bounds not Exact
Solutions your computer should really
beat humans in this and it does as you
see in applications you plug it you get
you get an huge Improvement what people
were trying to do before over what
people were trying to do
before for any Epsilon positive number
Epsilon you can think of it as Epsilon
time K1 okay yeah K1 is kind of the
identity of the albra so and uh what we
show is that the answer to this question
is negative actually something even
stronger I'm going to mention later so
the what we first did was we constructed
a counter example to this but then we
find stronger results so uh because I'm
going to talk about the stronger results
I'll just mention this where this
construction comes from without really
giving you the proof so you talk about
positivity and sums of squares so where
should one look at of course pols right
uh and for
pols again we know sums of squares is
always positive and Hilbert first
observed that long time ago that there
are three variable positive homogeneous
polinomial which are not sums of squares
of polins so this question setting of
polinomial has a counter example one
simple one is mkin polinomial over three
variables 6 it's positive you can write
it as sums of squares of polins and what
we did we did was just we turn this into
something about Quantum so we uh we took
that and converted it to a Quantum graph
which writing it as sums of squares of
quantum graphs would imply that this is
also sums of squares of pols um so that
H 17 or L 17th problem was falsi by this
what kind
ofs uh no they're not that big so
they're
on T veres or
something
um okay so uh
well for polinomial you can write them
as sums of squares of polins but we know
that we can write any positive
polinomial as sums of squares of
rational functions so just um polinomial
divided by polinomial squar so this is a
result of tin from 27 which was an
answer solution to Hilbert 17th problem
and actually again ly in his collection
of open problems kind of expected that
the answer to the other one would be
negative and he also ask this maybe some
analog of Artin theorem would be true
but note that uh this has an interesting
consequence and that is that checking
the positivity of a polinomial is a
decidable problem you can do it by a
computer
and the reason is we do the following
two things in parallel first of all we
check the value of the polinomial over
rational numbers trying to negate it to
find to make it negative trying to find
some setting of rational numbers which
makes the polinomial negative and in
parallel we can also try to write it as
sums of squares so actually in this
theorem you can assume that coefficients
are rational so I have these two
countable sets I just go over all the
possible choices in parallel either at
some point I'll find some assignment of
to variables which makes the polinomial
negative or I'll be I'll succeed in
writing it as sums of squares so in any
case I'll know the answer whether it's
positive or not some point so this is
decidable and if the analog of AR
theorem would be true for Quantum graphs
the we'll also get decidability there
for verifying the POS uh validity
validity of those
inequalities
um okay uh
uh again uh so I mentioned these things
in previous slide
so we know what uh knowing this would
imply
decidability and actually amazingly no
one asked this
before neither LED nor um rasboro but
this is really the natural question to
ask and it's stronger than all of those
previous ones and what we showed is that
this is undecidable so given these
coefficients and graphs you can't
there's no algorithm which will tell you
whether this inequality
holds uh so I'll mention uh some the
main part of the
proof
um it's not really difficult it's a very
short proof and it's now actually in uh
L's book on this topic uh so this is
what I want to show given these
coefficients and graphs is it true that
this inequality holds for every graph
G equivalently I can work with
polinomial so linear and polinomial are
the same because of this trick we had
with replacing graphs with distraint
unions so it's equalent to saying that
given a polinomial and these graphs is
it true that if I assign these densities
to variables of the
polinomial uh it's always non negative
right
uh okay so this is the new statement
which was equivalent to what wanted to
do and I'm not going to give you exactly
the proof of this but I'm going to prove
something very similar which hopefully
will convince you that I me give you the
idea why this this is undecidable so
here note that all these densities are
coming from one graph G in this new
problem I'm going to be a bit uh looser
and the condition is a bit stronger that
I'm allowed to use densities of various
graphs G1 to GK so I have a polinomial p
over this 2K variables and the question
is if I substitute the edge density as
triangle densities of this K graphs is
it true that this is always non-
negative on the other hand it's very
simple right I'm just working with Edge
and triangle not even any fancy graphs
distin densities of edges and triangles
but K different graphs okay so the proof
of this is
not so difficult um so I'm going to use
two basic ingredients maybe the the
whole meat is here in mat which is
solution to Hilbert's 10th problem so he
showed that this deciding um whether a
polinomial is non- negative over sets of
integers so you're only allowed to
assign integer values to variables
that's undecidable you can't do that
using uh computer uh and you can just do
a simple trick and convert it to the
following instead of integers I'm going
to look at this this other countable set
and other discrete set so I'm interested
whether I can make this polinomial
negative over the set of uh numbers of
the form 1 - 1 / n this you can I'm sure
all of you believe that this is
undecidable knowing mich's
theorem okay so this is the main
ingredient the other ingredient is this
result of uh new result of rasboro fact
uh bash's older result would also suff
let me say what this means uh what this
results say so this picture here what I
have here describes completely describes
the relation between Edge density and
triangle density in a graph G so x axis
here corresponds to Edge density y AIS
corresponds to Triangle density and this
gray area is all the densities possible
densities that that can be achieved
using graphs or graph limits so it's a
closure of everything I can get with
graphs so any point here I can find the
graph limit whose Edge density is the x
coordinate and whose triangle density is
the y coordinate and Goodman's bound
which we saw before says that I mean
says that this triangle density is above
this Goodman's bound so this curve at
the bottom was Goodman's result and the
result of babash uh an old result of
babash says that this Goodman bound is
sharp only on points of the following
Form 1 - 1 / n so these are balance two
run graphs which show that this B good
man's bound is sharp and actually the
new result of rasboro is that it
completely describes this gray area
which says that uh the actual lower
describes the actual lower bound so it's
uh infinitely many uh curves here
separated so you see here there is a way
of using Edge density and triangle
density to get this discrete case right
discrete set that's the main idea of uh
proving the underside
ability uh okay so I'll give you the
reduction let s denote this gray area
and let G denote the good man's bound so
it's this curve uh here at the lower
part of this gray area 2x² minus X um
which correspond to Goodman's bound okay
so now I I have a polinomial p as an
input I'll con uh I'll I want to do a
reduction so I'll convert I'll use this
to construct the following polinomial Q
so Q is I multiply P by this positive
polinomial and I took this high enough
power to make it to kind of uh dump down
to make it a small number 1 - x i to the
6 and then here on this uh second term I
have a large integer C which depends on
P you can take the sums of coefficients
of P for example here or 10 times that
some large number just depends depending
on P times the following so y i minus G
of x
i now so this is my reduction I'm
claiming that the followings are
equivalent one is that we this thing
that P is negative can be ma made
negative by some assignment of to of
these kind of numbers to variables and
we know checking this is undecidable
because of mich's result and the
equivalent thing is that this new
polinomial Q is negative for some values
of XI and Yi which come from gray
area so all these things are only
allowed to be picked from the gray area
so let's see why is why that is true
first of all suppose uh so let me first
show this implication from top to bottom
suppose p is negative for this
assignment I can take these Yi to be
equal to gxi that's in the gray area for
these kind of points right so these are
where Goodman's bound matches the uh
gray area touches the gray area so this
part becomes negative p is negative and
I'm multiplying some positive number so
Q will be made negative so this
direction the right this is zero but
this one is positive right negative
sorry so I'm going to get a negative
value for Q now the other part is the
trickier part but again not so difficult
so now suppose Q is
negative uh for some assignment coming
from gray area why does does that mean
that P is negative for one of these
points the thing is if these uh X I are
not of this form then I know there's a
separation between this gray area and
this Goodman's bound so there is a
significant difference here between Yi
and gxi Y is strictly greater than gxi
and I'm multip multiplying that to a big
number here CP and I'm making P smaller
by multiplying it to this so basically
the derivative go in the right direction
and this term will will be more negative
than this can be positive so it will
make this whole thing
um so what did I want
say this is more positive yeah then this
can be more negative
exactly so P has to be negative in that
case too one of those
points okay so that's really just a
simple reduction and gray area we know
that just corresponds to what we get
from Edge density and triangle density
so this last equivalence is really
trivial I me not trivial really follows
from rasboro
result uh okay so that's the proof of
that undecidability that I had before so
this leaves us so where do we go from
here so this thing is undecidable is
there a nice General way of approaching
these
inequalities uh so one uh one thing now
we can do is well maybe we can hope
theability for some restricted class
classes of graphs and actually an old
result of babash implies that if you
have such a linear inequality involving
only clicks this is
decidable so
uh and basically bash's result says that
this is always minimized when you look
at these densities inside the clicks and
then you can optimize over that so this
is decidable uh maybe the next class one
wants to look at and is are polinomial
is involving click denses which
corresponds to linear inequalities
involving unions of clicks right
polinomial means just taking disjoint
unions so instead of clicks I'm allowed
to put unions of say triangle Edge so is
that
decidable um probably know but I don't
know any way of proving it uh another
really important thing is to understand
this monstrous object which is so for
every graph G as I said these things
correspond to kind of to we can think of
them as their MO as the moments of this
graph so for every graph G we get a list
of numbers which is can think of it as
as the statistics of G or it's the
profile of the G and this is a point in
the set 01 to the n and if you look at
all graphs G we get this set huge set of
points in 01 to the n and we can take
its closure let's call this R so this is
really a monstrous set we know very very
little about this for example it's not
even so easy to prove that it has
nonempty interior so that's an old
result of uh AES loas and Spenser from
thing late 60s or early 70s I remember
so they show that uh it has a positive
nonempty interior and what does rasboro
result for example say it just describes
the projection of this R to two
coordinates triangles and edges and so
even understanding the projection of R
to two coordinates was a very difficult
task so I mean seems describing the
whole set R is impossible but we can try
to understand more things about
it um okay so another way of approaching
these uh inequalities from General
perspective is through graph
limits uh so this is going to be my last
slide you uh so as Terry mentioned is in
his talk if you have a convergent
sequence of graphs you can represent the
limit as this nice object symmetric
measurable function from 01 Square to
01 now uh can think about talk about now
finitely forceable graph ones what are
these so these are points in R which are
uniquely determined by a finite number
of coordinates suppose I have this long
list of numbers profile of a graph and I
tell you a few coordinates say h density
and density of force cycle for cycle
that might determine the whole sequence
for example we know that's the case for
limits of random graphs if I know the Ed
deny of a graph of a graph limit is half
and the uh for cycle density is one 1
over 16 then I know this corresponds to
the W which is just the constant half
function which is the limits of random
graphs for example so that's finitely
possible so there was a I mean or still
maybe there's a general hope so there
are two related conjecture first is by L
see which says that if I
have uh such if I have an inequality
which is not valid or can think of it in
the other direction feasible
inequality uh the sum is at most zero so
there is some W which makes this
negative then there is also some
finitely forceable W it's a really
beautiful conjecture but we have no idea
how to approach it I don't I mean I talk
to bage and let see it's just there's
really no even no partial result another
equivalent way of saying it is that
suppose I give you some density say
density of edge density of triangle
density of force cycle and so on and we
know that there are some graph limits
satisfy these densities can I force can
I fix more densities to to get a
finitely forceable graph it's it might
be possible it might not so one uh
conjecture is this the second conjecture
which kind of not doing so well these
days that uh finitely forceable graphons
have simple
structures um so initially people
thought that uh they are just basically
step functions in the following sense
that uh they are just you take this 01
square and you partition it to some
parts like this and then they are
constant in different parts 0 one say
here Z half here so on so this was the
initial conjecture which very soon
refuted by constructing a finitely
forceable graphon which was of this form
one here zero here and then uh this
finite dimensional conjecture was one of
the last conjecture precise conjecture
which was saying that
um well I'll say what it says exactly by
mentioning this new announced result
which still the paper I haven't seen the
paper but glov kosova and Dan CW uh
which say that there are finitely
forcible W's such that the following
holds let's look at the rows of W's so
for every value of x let's look at the
this function WX and is a function of
the second coordinate right so you get
this set of functions and let's Endo
this space with L1 distance right W is
like a matrix but over
01 rows are indexed by interval 01 so
look at the rows with L1
distance this might contain a subset so
they constructed a final forceable W
such that this contains a subset which
is homeomorphic to 01 to Infinity so
it's really very infinite dimensional
this roset so the original conjecture
was that if you do this with L1 distance
this is always be a finite Dimension
actually what L andity had was that they
only knew constructions of
onedimensional objects but they they
kind of suspected that finite might be
possible and not infinite is not
possible then Serge norin uh which was
my coauthor in this work he constructed
D dimensional uh graph finite forceable
graphons for every D and then these
people extended those ideas and actually
managed to construct infinite Dimension
so in this I
mean this conjecture is kind of refuted
I don't know if there is any other
simple structure one might expect the
only uh positive Result One Knows is
that again due to L andity is that the
set of finely forceable graphons is a
first category Set uh so it's a
countable Union of nowhere dense set so
so it's it's very very Parts compared to
set of all graphons but no really
explicit structures now so I'll stop
yeah any
questions yes
if I give you some parameters like H
density triangle density can we sample
such graphs at random um random uh I
know there are some Works about that but
I'm not sure about the general a general
the yes I don't
say part of the question
oh say you take from the gray area how
to yeah the
model yes so bash result was that this
inequalities in clicks is decidable but
do we know what's decidable in pomal
time or is there any
conjecture I don't know if it's pomal so
it the decidability comes from the fact
that you only need to look at clicks for
that it's an optimization of that
probably
it's
yeah question was so let's say this is
polinomial either any reasonable
conjection what might be decidable in
polinomial
time no I don't know yeah actually that
one thing about this area is that for
some reason computer scientists haven't
uh been uh working on this area that
much as I think they should it's mostly
really pure mathematicians and
combinator it's really I mean it's very
computer science area you apply these
techniques you can actually find proofs
using them and then there are questions
about exactly how efficient you can be
for certain problem so I think it should
be more
advertising yes so maybe it's the case
that inequalities between three graphs
or four graphs can yeah maybe so what we
have is I think between know nine graphs
10 graphs something like that
algebraical yes yeah yeah yeah
not this corresponds to being able to
deal with but
not thank H
again